So funny you should say that because
we have a thing that I'm going to
call the fundamental theorem of PSRs,
but
we can just call it the PSR theorem,
that says specifically,
any end state POMDP can be represented
by a predictive state representation.
>> Or PSR.
>> With no more than n tests, each of
which is no longer than n steps long.
>> So that's good.
But also you just introduced something,
the number of steps.
I guess I didn't think about that
before, since both of those tests were
sort of ones-
>> They were very short, right, yeah.
But it's not hard to come up with
an example like that, right.
I'm writing it as a POMDP because I
am a limited beast and it's hard for
me to think about PSRs.
So what might a test be that you'd need
to represent POMDP written like this?
So we've got white state, white state,
black state, black state.
So one step test would be
things like if I go, well,
there's only that one action, and I see
white, what's the probability of that?
That's not enough information
to know where we are, right,
and in fact, seeing back is
also not enough in this case.
We actually have to think about
what happens in two steps from now.
>> Right, so yeah, yeah, so you could
say if your test is two steps away then
I could, for example, figure out
>> If I see a white and
then I see a black, then I know I
must have been in the bottom state.
>> Right.
>> If I see black after making one move,
then I had to be in one
of the two middle states.
>> Right.
>> And I guess if I took two steps and
I saw white twice,
then I know I had to be in
the top state, for example.
>> So are you saying that you think
we need another test to make this go?
>> Well, I don't know.
It just occurs to me that
I can figure out that
I'm in the top state if I see
two white ones, that's all.
I'm just pointing that out.
>> Wouldn't it be enough to just know,
okay, if I go up, will I see white, and
then go up and see black?
If the probability of that is 0 and
going up and eeying black,
the probability of that is 0.
>> So if going up I see black,
the probability is 0.
Then I have to be in either
the top state or the bottom state.
And if it's also the case if I
will not be able to see white and
then black then that tells
me what state I must be in.
>> Yeah, that was the thought.
>> Right, yeah, yeah,
sure, sure, sure, sure.
>> But these longer tests
are really important here.
Just having the single step doesn't
give you enough information,
doesn't give you enough constraint.
>> With those two tests,
can I alone figure out everything?
Can I completely-
>> So
I think it's like the other example that
we looked at, which is if we know that
we're in one of these states, top,
second, third, fourth, then I
think these two tests are enough to tell
us which of those four things are in.
But in general, a belief state
might be something like well,
0.6 of the top one and 0.2 of the second
one and 0.1 and point something else.
So in that case,
we've got a four dimensional vector,
actually a three dimensional vector,
because it has to add up to 1,
that we're trying to specify
in term by way of two numbers.
And we get that same kind of
indeterminacy that you worked us
through in the other example.
>> I see, okay.
So this kind of makes me
want to ask a question.
>> Okay.
>> Why does this help?
Why should I bother going to PSR,
other than the mathematical niceties?
>> There are some examples
where it helps, and
part of it is a philosophical thing.
It's got to be better for
us in the long run to represent our
world in terms of things that we can
actually observe instead of things
that we can never, ever observe.
So that's kind of the philosophical
point that this answers.
There is, as far as I'm aware,
the literature that I'm familiar with in
terms of learning a POMDP,
you can learn a PSR representation.
It may be easier than learning
a POMDP representation.
But the thing that I find
interesting is that there's
POMDPs that are easy to learn, and
there's POMDPs that are hard to learn.
And the POMDPs that are easy to
learn are easy to learn as PSRs and
the POMDP that are hard to learn
are hard to learn as PSRs.
So there's almost sort of this
underlying toughness of the POMDP itself
or the environment itself that switching
to PSRs doesn't seem to exactly help.
There is a case, though, when certain
of the attributes of the problem
are continuous, where in fact,
it can be shown
that a PSR representation can actually
be learned efficiently when the POMDP
representation's not clearly
learned efficiently.
>> I mean, I suppose one nice
thing about the test model,
at least in a particular
case where there's some 1 or
0 probability of a test coming
out under certain circumstances,
it might be easier to think about what
you ought to do in order to figure out
exactly where you are.
Like the set of tests you might run so
that you can completely determine
where it is you are in the real,
sort of underlying world.
>> Just knowing that
might be a useful thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, for control and yeah,
discovery.
>> Right.
>> Yeah,
I mean, I'm not familiar with
papers that do that exactly.
>> Yes, you are.
>> Do
you have a paper that does that exactly?
>> Holmes and Isabel.
>> I guess I wouldn't
think of it that way.
>> I always thought of it that way.
Or at least so Tinder told me that
I should think about it, though.
[LAUGH] I didn't think about it
that way until he told me I should.
>> And in particular, that's
Tinder Singh who, his group did a lot of
the pioneering work on PSRs and had some
very nice analyses for how they work.
So yeah, okay, but I just wanted
to give kind of a sense of this.
There is some more
recent work using least
squares methods instead of probabilistic
methods that actually can lean on this
PSR idea to learn efficiently actually.
If you have enough data, it can actually
turn it into a model that predicts well,
and the model has elements
in common with PSR.
So it has gotten some leverage.
I think the jury's still
out as to whether or
not this is really the way we want to
represent our environments, but
it's a useful tool for the toolbox.
>> Yeah, I can see that.